Zach was telling me that you were
supposed to go to the Bahamas this
weekend with your family yeah there's
something that I need to tell you my
family is not in the Bahamas why is that
dear well this is going to sound weird
but hey I just heard about Zach is he
okay he has a concussion he needs to
take it easy come on you know the
statistics on there he's right Zoe this
is Miles Zach's cousin hi oh the the
soccer player mhm dude you're lucky it's
not worse that's because Zoe saved my
life not
exactly miles is in grad school at MIT
oh he's just visiting for the weekend I
hear that that's a really great school
yeah
thanks dude I can't believe you weren't
wearing a helmet you got to be more
careful is the bike destroyed so you
were telling me about your family
trip oh we had to postpone it
something came
up